out
okay so um
being 1204
in accordance with the house calendar uh
division three is meeting is the chair
of division three of the house finance
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covet 19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020-04 is extended this public
body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order i'm
confirming that we are providing public
access
to this meeting by telephone with
additional possibility via
other electronic means the committee is
using zoom for this remote meeting all
members of the committee and the staff
of state agencies with agenda items have
the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously watch and or
listen on the meeting on zoom or on the
phone
following the directions and links that
we provide in the house calendar the
current house calendar is number 15
and the instructions for these meetings
have been posted since
calendar number eight
so
in the house count that same house
calendar you'll you'll notice the public
notice
um on
how to use
uh
access us using the telephone
we provide
the public with a mechanism to let us
know if you're having problems with
access you need to email us at lba
underscore f-i-s-c-a-l
at l-e-g
dot state dot nh dot u s we will adjourn
the meeting if the public is then able
to access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
please
you may note that we're going to meet
every day
until we complete the budget at this
point monday through friday
please note that all
all votes that we take shall be done by
roll call
and there may actually be one of those
today
so um let's start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance as the media
member says uh that they're here if
you'll let us know who else is uh can
overhear you so that we know what's
going on under right to know
so uh representative weiler are you
ready to take the role sir
okay
representative weiler is president in
kingston there's no one else in the room
representative earth
president uh home alone my home office
representative bean
i'm at home in guilford my wife is
around here and then the dog
representative
i'm in my home in concord and i'm at
alone
representative nordgren
representative norgren i'm
at my house in hanover and i'm in my
dining room slash office
representative rogers
i'm uh catherine rogers i'm in my
apartment in concord and there's someone
here that's just come back from walking
romeo they'll be here short leaving
shortly
representative edwards i'm in my home
office in auburn uh i have family in the
house but the office door is closed
all members of prison
all right
so
um uh
this this meeting was noticed in the
house calendar uh the focus we're gonna
put on it today is really
uh walking through
uh house bill 2.
even though
we've had people come and talk to us
about their house bills house bill 2
proposals we've never done any level
setting between the committee members
and so
given that we
intend to break at 2 30 because uh
we have committee members with other
obligations this afternoon we don't
really have time to to get into the
details of each of the items
so what i think we can do is go through
every issue
once
uh on kind of a
a treetop level
and and just get a sense on
if there are
if there are any committee members
that have concerns about the house bill
or want to do additional research or
or if they're just fine with it as is
so um i've emailed you uh what i'm
looking at so
um
so i won't i won't shh
maybe i should share
i'm gonna go ahead and share maybe it'll
be easier that way
okay i think i'm sharing because i can't
tell which document i'm sharing i think
i'm sharing one that says house bill 2
list is is that what's there and is it
big enough should i make it bigger
it's big enough it starts with number
20. it's in the index yes sir okay all
right
so
so again
i don't think the purpose of this is
really to
uh to decide anything but just to get a
sense from from the uh committee
on uh if you have issues with it so when
i so when i come to one of them
what i'm i'm going to ask you to do
is to raise your hand
if you have
a possible amendment or you know
something that we we need to know
um
and if you're just generally okay with
the
house bill 2 as it's described you you
don't have to raise your hand that way
we can keep going
but anyone who raises their hand will
have an opportunity to speak a little
bit about
what what what they think about the
section
so
um so let's give this a try i i will
start out with section 20
the sale of the lakes region facility
um there was a a proposal in there
um
and i
i
i don't know the history on
the laconia
state park area or whatever it's
technically called
but i do know that
senator french is working on an
amendment to that that particular
section
and i don't even know
what he intends to do but i know that
he's uh coordinating with the state reps
in that area and that's everything i
know representative walner
um
i think this is section 19. you you
probably maybe you were using the um
the draft
guilty is charged i use the draft i just
i was just looking at the um trying to
look at the sections and this is the
laconia state school facility
and
i think this has been in here for for a
while
am i right kevin
i think it has been i'm not sure if
division one has acted on that section
yet or not
okay so uh mr williams said yellow
highlighted it as a dhhs issue you think
it's a division
two issue
i think it was originally assigned to
division one
let me just take a look yes division one
has that one
yeah
we can just keep going then i think
so so representative wallner based on
that i'm going to assume that every one
of my numbers is one too high and i'll
correct them
and if
if you'll correct me if i do one wrong
i'd appreciate it did you have a
follow-up ma'am
no
no that one was easy wasn't it we gave
it to division one
yeah i like that an action passed as an
action completed
uh okay so
this this next one was related to
quarterly reports from the commissioner
and i i didn't see an issue
and so i was just curious if uh
dhhs is uh going to object to it or if
there's any uh resistance on this one
representative wallner you have your
hand up
um i think that this one's been with us
for a while in um
past budgets also
so this has just become standard
boilerplate
i mean they don't they don't always do
quarterly reports even though we've told
them to
so is there any reason for us to want to
modify it in any way
to start uh
penalizing them ten thousand dollars a
quarter or
are we
are we okay any good
will be okay with the language as is
yeah maybe they'll maybe they'll listen
this time
you do have uh well
karen had her hand raised in the
audience but i think she lowered it
representative your hand is still up do
you have a follow-up nope i'm putting it
down sorry
no problem so i'm gonna move on with
that with the summary note
that this is a boilerplate and uh we're
okay with the language
if you if you change your minds later uh
reach out and let me know
so the next one is section 21 i believe
department of hhs uh unfunded positions
and
and it says authorization discussion
does does anyone have
comments on this one
yes uh two hands let's go uh i think he
went first representative erf what do
you have to say
sir i was just gonna say we might want
to look at that one i really hadn't
delved into it too deeply but
okay so we're at this point you're just
saying we just need to look at it you
don't have a position on it
i don't yet have not really i should
honestly have not been through this yet
i probably should have but
all right no no
representative wilder your hand is up
sir
yes because of uh all the money that is
has got to come out of this budget i
don't think we should remove this i
don't think we should accept this
because it just says go on and do the
hiring they can't find the people
they've had such rapid expansion there's
more expansion than the budget can
sustain
and i think we need to do something and
this might be the place to say you know
freeze the hiring
don't fully don't fill the unfunded
positions
okay so for the people in the audience
who are getting nervous
uh where i type in here
all that all all the money that needs to
come out
this section may need to be eliminated
but how you should interpret that is we
have a conversation that we need to have
around this
so
don't
don't panic yet please
uh
do you have any other uh comments sir uh
representative weiler
sorry i'll lower my hand no i i just
think that
for the good of trying to balance a
budget we can't uh allow all this
filling of unfunded positions
okay so um so time permitting uh
if we get to the end and we still have
some time
i think we can come back to a few of
these
all right
so
uh i think
section 21 and i'm not watching the uh
attendees mr ripple
are you watching the attendees i am
nobody has their hand up at the moment
okay and i i don't know how much we have
time we have to entertain
the
questions from the attendees but
if you if you see one that you think we
need to hear from um you know let me
know
okay
it's because my goal is to get from the
top to the bottom
at least once today
um
not just not to solve anything but just
to know
all right
so section 22
this is a suspension of the foster
grandparent program
and i i know
that somebody has said something to us
about this but
does anyone know why
we're suspending
something that sounds so great a foster
grandparent program
uh representative walner
actually i think in past budgets we
when there was no funding available for
it
it has been suspended but if i read this
one
i think this actually repeals it
am i right kevin that's right this is an
outright repeal in past budgets it's
typically been suspended
in the current 2021 budget uh both
congregate housing and the foster
grandparent program were actually funded
i think you heard from the department
that they didn't request funding this
time around
and it looks like this time the decision
was made
perhaps by the governor's office perhaps
by the department i'm not sure to go for
an outright repeal rather than a
suspension
you have a follow-up representative
no i just would like to leave this one
open so that we can talk a little more
about it
so i'm going to put your name on it so
that the next time we talk more about it
you'll start the conversation is that
okay
i think we're on section 23
and this is a repeal
uh relative to congregate services and
my questions were why and are there
objections
i think if i could i think that section
came out i think that was all
consolidated into the new section 22.
so section 23 is now the social services
block grant cost of living adjustments
okay so
so we'll we'll have one conversation
instead of two
all right
very good so
the draft 25 is that now 23 or 24
it is now 23.
this is a block grant cost of living
adjustments
for two
okay so
this is giving a cost of living
adjustment for the eligibility criteria
and that
would raise
eligibility
in the cola that would be used would be
consistent with the federal colon that's
what i think is going on here is there
any is there any history or objection to
that that we need to hear are we okay
with this or
does this need more discussion
i'm gonna
wait another second uh representative
earth
is this something
new kevin that they've put in
this is not new it's been in before i'm
just checking now to see if the language
is the same as it was in the previous
biennium
and then represent nordgren you you
can't ask a question or say something if
you want if you change your mind no i
was going to ask the same question keith
asked so
wait for kevin to figure it out
thanks
it looks
like the language is identical
follow-up there representative
so i'm just i guess i just want to so
why would it be an hb
is this essentially giving raises to
certain
phrases is the wrong word but increasing
eligibility
amounts this is this is one that if you
i would actually ask somebody from the
department to come in and explain this
if they're
if they're willing i'm not sure if john
okay let's see
so
john williams in the audience do you
want me to bring him in yes sir uh and
just to remember what we're trying to do
today we're just trying to do
drag a comb through this so that we know
which ones are okay and which ones we
have to work on later and i think we've
already heard enough that says we want
to come back to this when we
when we have time
okay
so but i will say that we'll come back
and uh
mr williams uh can lead that
conversation once we get started okay
all right so the 26 i think becomes
24.
and
uh this is about county reimbursement of
funds limitations on payments
uh representative irfi i imagine you
have things to say about this
definitely to keep this one open yes
so i had asked the question in my notes
how do these numbers change
based on our conversations
so so so next time we come back and we
spend time about this
we will you be ready to do uh kind of a
presentation on this section with your
recommendation
of keeping or changing the language
please sure
are there any other comments from the
committee
we support representative irv
okay
so
quick question do we have a
date yet when we're going to be
discussing this particular thing again
or that would just be coming along at
some point in the future
okay we have scheduled um
a meeting every day between now and the
26th actually okay every monday through
friday
so
based on today
and this pass i wanted to
start to sort these because i'd like to
go ahead and vote some of them out just
so we're we quit talking about them and
so we can start focusing on the ones
that we need to focus on
so let me ask you this question answer
your question with a question
if you're going to lead this
conversation and talk to us about any
proposed changes to language how much
time do you need to prepare for that a
day's notice
two maybe but one certainly would be
good monday is two days from now right
monday but i definitely prepared for
monday yes
is monday your next plan meeting on hp2
we
if you look at the calendar
what mr ripple has had done for us is
he's had us
on the calendar scheduled to talk about
hb1 and hb2 every day between now and
the 24th
and he's working with janet to extend
that to the 25th and 26th just to handle
the worst case scenario
but so i believe that because it's in
the calendar as long as we stay within
the scope of the that topic we're okay
is is that correct mr ripple is that
your interpretation
it is i'm not sure that monday's meeting
specifically says house bill one and two
but as long as it's a division work
session and it's noticed in the calendar
i i think you're covered
just so
is your plan to take up 832 again on
monday is that what you're thinking
right i might i'm not thinking anything
except i want to get all the way through
this list so that i know what we have on
our planet then you will let us know is
that accurate
at some point
yes okay thanks
yes
all right
um
okay so
this um
so i'm just going to put representative
irf leads
and then i'll just go monday
question mark okay we'll come back to it
so this
27 becomes 25 perspective repeal
regarding eligibility of services that's
extended
and i want to go try to do some work on
this to figure out what what the heck
this was
and i couldn't follow these citations i
don't know
what we're amending what we're extending
i have no clue
what's inside of this one
i can i can provide some background on
that one if you'd like
please
this relates to access to the state's
mental health system
and some language was put in place back
in 2011
that
restricted access to treatment and other
services based on the availability of
appropriations and there was some whole
language around that that language was
originally intended to be repealed on
july 1st of 2013
and it's for cost-saving reasons it's
been extended every biennium since and
this would do the same
this has become this has achieved a
boilerplate status
it has by now yes
so if we wanted to reduce boilerplate
and and put this in some rsa where it
belongs
do we need different language
the rsa is currently in place what you
have is a prospective repeal
that ends up getting pushed out two
years every biennium
so would the hb2 move just be a repeal
instead of another
the the current language extends the
repeal date by two years so if you were
to look up this statute online you would
see the existing language
you would see that that's repealed
effective i think july 1st 2021 now
and you would see the revised language
that's set to replace it all this
section does is extend that repeal about
yet another two years
okay so i'm not communicating very well
or i'm just confusing myself a little
bit
okay
rather than having every budget carry a
boilerplate item in it
why don't we just
do it once
and and not have to do this this section
every two years oh i see
what language would we need to
use in section 25
to get rid of this issue on a permanent
basis instead of kicking it down the
road two years
i think if the committee wanted to do
that you would just
remove the prospective repeal altogether
we'll we'll discuss that but i i'd like
i'd like to have us make a decision if
we just want to kick the can again
all right and is are there any other
comments on that because i i think
that's enough to let us move on
okay so
section 26
um
prospectively repeal regarding the
exemption from certain transfer
procedures extended
so this sounds like green eye shade
stuff what what what what are we doing
and do
is this the right language
do you want to speak right now
representative nordgren or do you want
mr ripple to explain
pardon me i had my hand up um could when
we talk about section 25
can we please have the department come
in and tell us
what our actions would mean to them
yes ma'am if we're considering another
action other than keeping it in house
bill 2.
yeah i
yes and just to be clear what my thought
was was this section might be rewritten
so that it doesn't come back every two
years that we just write it once and
or or get the rsa to say what we wanted
to say i don't know
but yes to your question the department
will
will be invited to speak all right thank
you
yes mr ripple did you want to talk about
this
section 26 uh sure
so that's another prospective repeal in
this case it has to do with the
department's transfer authority
current rsa reads that with respect to
all departments no transfer shall be
made from any appropriation items for
permanent personal services to any other
use or purpose
and then there are certain restrictions
upon that hhs has an exemption from that
limitation so with prior approval of the
fiscal committee they are currently
authorized to move items to move funding
out of personnel class lines
and
this
section by extending the repeal date
will allow them to do that for another
year and a half i'm not entirely sure
why this is extended until january 1st
instead of the end of the biennium
but that's something
that perhaps the governor's office could
speak to at a later date if he wanted
representative weiler
thank you
most agencies are not allowed to move
money from a personnel
or employee pay line to somewhere else
because many of them were were using
that gimmick years ago when somebody
would retire they'd spend the money on
something else rather than leave it in
there which was the design
to uh
in order to
fill up the money for the retirement
systems they were going to use the
surplus funds so
at one point there was a special
exemption for hhs
and then i guess that
we decided that that would be
suspended for a while so
it was kind of a special deal that was
given to hhs but i don't think it's
appropriate to still have it
so your recommendation would be to to to
not uh include section 26 again
that's right and then it will revert to
the common language for all the other
all the other uh
agencies they can't use personal
funds for anything else so so i i assume
ms rounds is listening but the next time
we talk about this the department can
certainly speak in up on
what the impact she thinks that would
have or whoever she thinks needs to talk
on that
i don't want to do it today um
are there any other comments on this
representative uh walner or nordgren
you've seen this line item for a while
do you have anything you want to add
representative
no i just think it would be important
that the department be able to come up
and comment when we could come back to
it because i think they have specific
reasons why they need these
these um footnotes or
hb2 sections yes ma'am i think i think
i'd also be curious if uh if we've ever
had a performance audit to suggest that
this authority's been abused or or is
just a bad auditing
practice
who who would be able to speak to the
uh if there's anything in an audit
finding anywhere on this
i'm not aware of any audit findings on
it i can um
again i think i'd have to check with the
department on that
i'm not either
i think you're the kind of a walking
encyclopedia sir on on our audits so i
read them all
okay so
um i believe
i believe the next one is the
section 27
and what this seems to be adding
is that
revenue from the medicaid enhancement
tax
is going to be used to meet the
requirements of rsa 167 64.
and and so i put a link to that rsa and
and i just am curious do we have any any
concerns or issues about that i look to
the more senior members of the committee
who
um maybe have been following the funding
of the
state advantage over the years of three
four years
um
you know
that medicaid enhancement tax has always
been used
to help uh cover the
bills for the
uh nursing homes
but i haven't looked up that that law
so so why don't i just say we're gonna
have further discussion on that
okay
and uh and i think the issue that you're
uh
suggesting is that is this diverting
money from the nursing
care programs
and then representative wallner are you
recognized when we go back to this one
um i think it would be good to have mr
lippman here
to explain it it i think this
gets pretty complicated
um
so i would want to make sure that um
he was here to to give us the
correct way of interpreting what this
language does
uh i i think i think that's that's wise
um what
um
i'm trying to think through
the uh
notice
rules the rules that we have on notice
our house calendar
i think gives us some flexibility what
what i'm thinking of doing is once we
get through this
uh schedule scheduling these items on
various days
in a sort of an informal way to invite
the department
is that does that work mr ripple
or do we need to like wait for a formal
calendar notice to invite
certain members of the department in you
you don't need to wait for a formal
calendar notice i think the notices that
exist
in the calendar going forward that just
say work session budget work session or
hospital one and two work session are
sufficient
the only thing i would point out is that
i
sorry to go off topic slightly here but
i took a look at the calendar for monday
and it doesn't explicitly say work
session and it doesn't explicitly say
house bill one and two so i'm emailing
the clerk now
uh for his opinion on whether he thinks
you can talk about house bill 2 on
monday from my perspective there's no
problem i'm i'm sure the committee's
done it before in similar circumstances
but i i can ask the clerk if you'd like
please do i i just
i
i i certainly don't want to abuse our
public notifications i think
that's article 38 of our constitution to
be continuously transparent to the
public and i want to i want to do that
so
but i i do want us to finish on time
representative weiler
just a quick comment on the medicaid
enhancement tax i think i was the author
of it 18 years ago or something like
that so what we did was we put up a tax
on all the hospitals earnings
and then we turned around and gave the
money back to them
and then the feds matched the money we
gave to them
even though it was theirs originally
anyway so
and then through the history of it there
were some years where we didn't give
everything back and they sued us
but because of the
match that we were using to give them
money
it was medicaid money and if they didn't
have enough medicaid patients then they
didn't get everything back that we had
charged them so it was
kind of a controversial thing but it was
a dodge to get more medicaid money thank
you
i just for the record i i think what you
said it was a legal dodge
of course
all right um all right so
you know because mr lippman is so busy
if the department could come back to us
and tell us
what what which of these work sessions
works best for him the the the next
the very next one he can make work would
be perfect
john williams does have his hand raised
in the audience he'd like me to bring
him in
yes and
oh he did hold on a second
i just want to remind people that the
goal today is not to solve anything it's
just uh i identif you know do a triage
to figure out
what's what we need to do with these
and mr chair uh good afternoon and
members of house finance division three
this is john williams uh the director of
legislative affairs and i just uh wanted
to make the committee aware that uh miss
rounds uh and myself have coordinated to
having uh several department folks
available to you today to hopefully be
able to answer some of the questions you
are raising and i believe currently on
this call is director henry lipman so if
you do have questions it's certainly as
long as you feel uh comfortable that
this has been appropriately calendared
and we certainly are doing a walkthrough
of hb2 right now
we could certainly answer many of your
questions either
after you do your initial walkthrough or
coming back through again but we are
committed here to be a resource to you
and the committee
i i appreciate that and um i i i want to
accomplish the objective of getting
through everything once to get a triage
on it because as a committee we've not
talked to one another yet about any of
these things
and so this is the first time that we've
had a chance to talk to each other
so so
let us if you will let us get through it
um so that we we know where all the
rocks are and and then we can come back
and start poking down
i think um i think we'll come back to
that one
and i will yellow highlight it
since we know that mr lippman is in the
audience
so
um number 28
um state treasurer and state accounts
and when i looked at this i didn't see
an issue but i i wanted to make sure
that uh the committee
told me if they saw an issue or not
so think about it for a moment raise
your hand if you have an issue
yes representative earth i don't know
that i have an issue can kevin explain
what it's doing
sure i think it simply creates a new
dcyf fund that accepts gifts grants and
donations but there's no
appropriation made of general fund
dollars or any other or any other
dollars in the operating body
thanks
all right
so
so i i don't i don't
see this one as is gonna be hard as
being a hard thing
uh
so then there's a new section and this
should be
section 29.
um
establishing emergency services
fund i guess it's a fund for dcyf and as
i read it
the questions that came to my mind
was it seemed like it was given a lot of
flexibility on how to spend state money
and and and therefore
it made me wonder if we had uh reporting
and transparency issues and
accountability issues
so i i i had a question on this
that uh i wanted to talk through
um
to just find out what the sense of the
committee is is this
is this appropriately scoped or bounded
and are do we have proper
separation of duties and and
reporting around it
or am i just overreacting to it because
it's uh something new i don't know so so
i would like to uh
have
have you look at it and um
i'll uh i'll come back to it when we can
schedule it but i'd like to know what
people think about
whether it's
the scope is too loose and if we've got
the proper controls
all right so
does anyone have any comment now before
i go to the next section
okay
parental reimbursement
and so i think my only question is what
is the impact of this
mr ripple
i'm putting you on the spot parental
reimbursement
and this is one that i think you would
want the department to come in and offer
an explanation of
precisely what it does and why they need
it
i'm not seeing any hands up from the
committee
and then
okay
so this is another what is the impact of
this
uh we're eliminating parental
reimbursement which doesn't sound like
anything we want to do but
that i don't understand what this
program does is what what are we doing
here
should we have the department come back
and speak on this
i think you should
you've had some yes
at one point if if um
your child ended up in
uh chins program or in the dcyf for a
year
it was about a hundred thousand dollars
that the parents were supposed to pay
back even if they had to take a mortgage
out on the house the kid was in there
for one year that parents might have 20
years of payments
then we went down to well you only had
to pay while the child was there so we
decided it was 300 a month you could
afford then you'd pay 300 a month while
your child was in dcyf
and then once they were out you didn't
have to pay it now everybody complained
about what they were having to pay
so
this is probably the
reason why we're doing this
and this subject has been the topic of
some bills that have been before the
legislature before and i don't recall
what the financial impact was i don't
think this would have a big impact in
terms of
revenue if you approve this section but
again i would want the department to
speak to that right
and just just to be clear i i'm probably
less concerned about the money than just
what's going on with the underlying
program when we do this
representative
i was just going to say that
i think we had testimony in the past
that the cost of the collections
um pretty much canceled out the
collection so
um
i i think the department should come and
talk about it
did you want to expand on that
representative
i cut you off
i was going to say the same thing the
cost of collection was probably more
than what they collected
all right so
um
so the next one i think i'm losing my
numbering
uh is the is the next one 31
the next one
the hhs program eligibility additional
revenues is now section 32.
so i think the next one we have to talk
about i refer to as the weiler rule
and this is that they have to come in
and
if there's they can't just assume a
federal eligibility change without
telling us and having us formally
approve it that's correct and this is
language that's been in the past several
trailer builds
i assume
that everyone is okay with this is there
anyone who is not okay with with
continuing the weiler rule
all right
so
so the next one
and again i'm messing up my numbers i'm
sure i am
so
dhhs excess revenue from federal match
programs i read it it sounded reasonable
to me
is it reasonable
does anyone find it unreasonable somehow
if i could the only comment i would make
about this and i see that karen has her
hand raised in the audience is when you
discussed this the last time when we
went through house bill 2 briefly i
think the governor's office mentioned
that they might want to suggest some
alternative language
oh
what what are they going to do there
i'm not sure
i can follow up though
let's uh let ms round speak in case she
knows something okay
hi thank you uh yes the um
i am working with the governor's office
on alternative language and i should
have that completed this weekend so i
hope to have that too early next week
that's fantastic
because because it's going to get cold
again this weekend and you don't want to
be outside
true story cold and windy
okay uh do you have anything else to say
ms rounds i think i captured it
not on that item nope
uh so
help me get back on my numbering schema
mr ripple what is
the services for developing
developmentally disabled what line what
section number is that
well i think there are some sections in
between now
i think there's a section
that one may have come out entirely
because i don't see it in the
yeah i don't see that in the in the
trailer bill the next section that i
have the section that you just reviewed
the excess revenue from federal match
programs is 33.
and the next is reproductive health
facilities section 34.
and so so that is number 34.
and on this one
i know that there's a proposed language
coming to replace what's in 34.
um but i've not seen the language
and i don't i don't know how big a deal
it's gonna be
but uh but we're gonna have to uh talk
about this
in detail i'm sure
so uh unless somebody wants to say
something i'm ready to move to the next
one
okay so i i i'm thinking it's the
appropriation for alvarez and and uh
martinez martinel
anyways the a m study
and uh
what so what number is that 35
35.
so when i looked at this i'm i'm just
thinking hey
i can't put 10 million dollars in there
until i see what they're saying and
um because they may have said something
brilliant or something that nobody
really agrees with
if we just put the money in there and
say we're going to implement their
findings
it seems to me like we're giving up our
role as a legislator to a contractor and
i don't care to do that
so
so i i i have a heavy bias
to just stripping but maybe keeping the
line of the section in there and taking
it down to one dollar or something so
that you know if uh if the senate wants
to add it back because they've read the
report or the fiscal committee in a year
you know wants to transfer money that
there's an account there but but my my
bias on this is uh
one dollar not 10 million or or even
less than a dollar if we if we don't
need the language
so representative weiler do you have a
comment sir
your hand is up and you're on mute
if you hit the control bar or the space
bar you can
thanks i don't i don't think it's so
much to pay for the study itself it's
pretty heavy
money to pay for a study but i think
it's to pay for the recommendations as a
result of the study
yes sir i agree and that's what i'm
saying
10 million dollars to implement
recommendations we've not even read
just doesn't seem reasonable
do you do do you agree or disagree sir
i agree
okay representative
unfortunately i need a magnifying glass
to read it
uh we did get from karen rounds we did
get um
where the where where the funds would go
what the funds would do
um i agree i would like to see the
report
i would like to see what it does but we
do have a we do have this breakdown from
her
um which
does designate where these funds would
go
and i think i i would at least like to
next week when um
we have the department here i'd like to
hear more about this and hopefully the
report will come soon
okay so
so i'm going to say
that we want the department to come back
and brief us when the report is
available
and and i my position is
that
i i'm not i can't approve any money
until i've read the report or have had
an opportunity to
so that's that's just me and we'll end
up talking and voting at some point
um representative nordgren
yes i was going to ask mary jane's
question
but i also
am discouraged that we are in this
middle of this process and we have yet
to see the report so i hope that would
be forthcoming pretty quick
thanks
yes yes ma'am i i think we share a
perspective there and based on what we
heard from senator clay wednesday
afternoon there's a couple of other
reports i think we should ask for
and ask for all three at once because
they they seem to all have the same
general impact area and i i i want to
i i
i'd like to see the whole picture so
um so
so mr uh ripple could you could you make
that a request over to the department
that we want all three reports
sure
thank you sir
uh representative walter your hand is
out
oh
are we on 36 yet
we're on health and human services
suspension of catastrophic aid payments
to hospitals
is that 36 yes
okay well so
so why do we want to suspend
catastrophic aid that why is this a good
thing
well
i mean i think that uh we don't want i
mean i wouldn't want to
i wouldn't want to
take this section out i'd want to retain
this section
you know there's the possibility that at
some point
we may be able to fund catastrophic aid
so
i don't think we want i i i wouldn't
want to take this this section out
so i'm i'm putting in my note that
representative wallner wants retain and
discussion on it and will right
yes
perfect there any other comments or
questions at this point
so i'm going to assume the next one is
appropriation dhhs
services and sports for mental health
and social isolation
and as i looked at this
i had this very strong feeling of
why didn't that get put into a bill so
that a committee could hold public
hearings on it
um and
or alternatively
it read like something for which we
should already have a current program
that the money could go against and so
why are we using an hb2 section
to do something that should either
already be flexible in the law
or
should have been a committee bill
instead of hb2
that that that's my question do any of
the representatives want to speak to
that
representative irf
i'm just guessing based on what matt
said to us last time about another
uh item in here that i asked about that
it's a one-time approach they think it's
a one-time appropriate one-time
appropriation basically
i'm not not defending i'm just saying i
think that's why they put it in here
okay so you think this is the governor's
office
and
uh and then it may be a one
a one time thing
i had the impression that's why they
tend to put things into hp2 that's one
of the reasons they put things into hb2
are there any other comments on this
representative look like you're reaching
for your hand raised there
yeah thank you um
i mean i it would be interesting to know
who the senior centers are
just a little more information about
this since it is a
and it's a new item
i agree that's why i looked at it and
went why isn't this a bill that went to
a committee there you know some policy
committee should be having a social or
not social excuse me should that be
having a public hearing on this i think
so i i i don't know the culture around
hb2
um
but
but i i don't i don't like this one
um are there any other comments
so if we could mr ripple let the
governor's office know
matt or if he's if he's online that we'd
like to have another pass at this to
figure out why this wasn't a bill
okay
is the next one appropriations expanded
in continued emission discharge and
transfer event notifications is that
number 38 yes
okay so this
struck me
uh similarly
there i i i we heard
the department or somebody come in and
tell us about how great it was to have
these uh adt
uh transfers going out to everyone so
that there would be some
situational awareness around the patient
status that sounded like a good smart
thing
um so
why why isn't this program just
authorized already
otherwise it feels like a committee bill
to me and and why are we trying to do
this in hb2 instead of
leveraging an existing program
or
sending this to a committee
any any of the reps have a comment on
that
agree representative
uh no
i'm fine
okay thank you representative erf do you
have a comment on that i agree with what
you said that relates to a few of these
are coming up
okay so similarly
uh mr ripple if we could i assume that
this was
who did this is this the governor or the
department do we know who sourced this
is her hand raised in the audience
i'm not sure who put it in there and i
see no hands uh looks like karen has
raised her hand
all right let's let her speak please
hi so this this was put in hb2 because
it was realized too late in the
governor's budget process that it should
have been in hb1 and hv1 had already
been completed um so this appropriation
i agree should be in hv1 um but they put
it in hv2 because it was too late to get
it into hp1
to hb2 hb1 oh my gosh i'm saying all the
wrong words
it was too late to get it in the regular
budget
you're speaking my language using the
words you just did so so but okay
if
we were to just put it into the budget
as part of the division three
amendment to hb1
can we just drop
this hb2 section because it really
becomes irrelevant yes yes and it would
go into the bureau of information
services
so so you'll you'll help us with a
little note on that so that we don't
lose it i can do that
would you like me to submit a change
request for it for hv1
no that's up to you and uh uh mr ripple
whatever mechanics you want to implement
there i i
you know how to work
okay
kevin i'll get you the information
just a quick question on that jess is
this is it intended to be
one year or is it intended to be
it ongoing to me like it's a good
ongoing program if
if there's clinical value in letting
people know about uh
admissions
discharges and transfers
then it's it's probably always a good
clinical idea and then
then they can start building up their
clinical or community
referral base
and rely on a a routine
announcement that somebody's re-entering
the community that's what i think this
does
did i say something incorrect there ms
rounds
no that i believe that's correct it is
intended to be an annual or
um
a regular expenditure
ongoing operations yes
okay so um
so 39
um
i think it's 39
this is the 60 bed forensic psychiatric
hospital
and my question was
should we be
doing this
when we are actively
asking ourselves what is the future of
the sununu center
what it what is what is the right way to
handle
um
our mentally ill adult and child
population and i'm i'm going to go to
representative walner
first because she and i talked last week
and and she said this is something that
she had some thoughts she wanted to
share so
so representative walner
do you still want to talk
sure i um
i mean i don't i don't really have any
great thoughts that i want to share but
this was in the last budget also and
i believe we
did not fund the entire
cost but we left in maybe
seven to eight million dollars i think
um to start the process of doing this
but of course because of the pandemic it
didn't it didn't get um underway which i
can certainly understand
i guess some of my questions are this
refers to
some federal funds that could pay for
this and i i'm really curious as to what
are those federal funds when will we
find out
um what are the strings attached to them
do we need matching money i mean there's
all sorts of questions i have about
what are these what federal funds and
then it says that if it's not funded
with federal funds or any part that
isn't
um
it will be bonded the 17.5 million
17.25 million dollars will be bonded
well that sounds like a capital
budget request to me
and i'm wondering why it isn't
in the capital budget request
and what does this
do
to do an offline
not in capital budget
uh bonding don't we have a bonding
formula that we're trying to
the state tries to stay within
so i just have a lot of questions about
how this how this would
really work
so i'm hearing a whole lot of extra
discussion on this one
yeah and the the other thing i would
like to have the department um
and maybe corrections i guess because
it's sort of a joint project
um talk a little bit about is there
really a need for 60 beds
it seems
seems large
okay
uh thank you for doing that and
representative nordgren
thank you thank you um i had similar
questions to mary jane and i just would
like to
bring up again the whole issue of
why this is in the capital budget um
there are limits for us
set by the treasury about our capital
budget and i'm just wondering if that's
why this is outside the capital budget
but we can get all those answers as we
put the package together to ask them
thank you
yes ma'am
representative walter your hand is still
up did you have follow-up yeah oh no
just
forgot to lower it thank you
are there any other comments about this
uh section
ripple you got any thoughts for us to
share or or do you think we're kind of
on top of this one
i have no thoughts except i believe the
department has answered some of those
questions in their
their responses but i need to figure out
which number that is and uh once i
once i find that i'll i'll email it back
out to you
all right
so
just to just to point a personal
privilege here for a second
because i have never gone through this
process before i didn't really know what
to expect and as a result
i
don't have a particularly great
filing system
to keep track of questions and the
responses that go with them and in the
general way in which i i get things is
by email
which which helps as long as you know i
can do searches on the email later but
microsoft office isn't a great
email system for even doing that so i
know you're putting everything out on
the website
um
i
i just uh it just starts to feel like an
easter egg hunt to me with an enormous
field in about 20 golden eggs but
i don't know where to go look so
i i'm just letting people know that if
it seems like
i'm breaking down a little bit on
aggregating data and keeping track of it
it's because i'm having
trouble so
um
appearances are what they are they
aren't deceiving in this case
and i would i would just call your
attention again to our website where we
have that tracking sheet with committee
requests it's getting pretty long but
everything on there should be numbered
and we're we're
posting the responses as they come in
um
all right so are we really on 39 here
with uh oh no we were on 39. so this is
going this is going to be a major
discussion i think
uh so this next one
transfer of
uh controlled drug prescription from
licensure to dhhs and
i have to admit when i heard this i went
well this is a no-brainer that makes all
the sense in the world
but then i happened to talk to
representative mcguire who has
been a chair and associated with the
licensure area for a number of years
and she told me informally that there
was an explicit reason they didn't put
it in dhhs and
and i i forget exactly what she said
but she gave me sort of a red flag that
this may not be a great idea after all
and
so i can i can try to get something more
formal from her
or or the committee members can tell me
what they think representative irf
if you're talking about 41a oplc
controlled drug prescription that seems
to be going to d1
no i'm talking i'm trying to talk about
um what would maybe number section 40
transfer of the control drug 40 is
military affairs
yeah no i think it's uh right after that
you got to skip that one yes get that
one and skip the next one well the next
one is uh new subdivision controlled
drug prescription health and safety
program that also goes to d1 according
to the index
it does this this is all now section 41
but uh division one has asked that
division three take it
oh
okay
we're transferring an ongoing operating
expense into division three which is if
if we accept this
but i think there was some operational
internal controls reason they wanted to
keep it separate
and and that's and that's what i think
the committee needs to hear unless you
guys already know the background on this
jesus oh excuse me
okay
so i'm gonna try to get something more
formal on it um
because i think it's important that we
double check that we're just not you
know one legislature's not talking to
another you know
um
all right i know if there's a department
in hhs that handles this
well
representative go ahead well i do think
didn't we we did have some discussion
about this
i don't even know when
but maybe it was maybe i dreamt it i
don't know but i think we did have a lot
some discussion about this because i
wanted to be sure that there was
conversation between
um
health and human services and the
existing light um agency
that hope that handles this
and um
i thought that they i thought they said
that they've been working on this for a
while this transfer
so you and you and i uh remember pretty
much the same thing we did talk about it
and i do remember that as i listened
it was all passing the common sense to
test to me that yeah this probably
belongs in dhhs
and what i'm what i'm trying to say is
that
after we had that uh
explanation from the department
i found myself talking to
representative carol mcguire who i think
you know
and she has kind of an encyclopedic
knowledge of of the history of a lot of
these things
and she told me that when this
um
drug prescription and health and safety
program was being formed
there was an explicit decision not to
put it into dhhs and i think she said
that there was a perception of a
conflict of interest of some kind and so
they intentionally put it into this
office of professional licensing
and
and so
i
i just want
us to look before we leap
and that we we kind of hear the other
side of the the other side of this
that that's that's what i'm saying does
that make sense representative waller
yes
makes perfect sense i just
who's going to give the other side
well i'm going gonna ask uh
representative mcguire to for her advice
on on what it would take for us to hear
the other side i mean she may just
write send us an email or something but
representative erf
my inclination me to strip it out and
like you said everything else jess why
isn't this going through the normal
process where public hearings uncover
these kinds of issues that you're
raising here
i think that's brilliant actually
and just before you move on uh patricia
tilly from the department does have her
hand raised in the audience
okay let's let's hear miss tilly
good afternoon thank you representative
edwards i just wanted to note that we
will be talking about this in some more
detail on monday when we finish the
division of public health services
walkthrough of our budget and so we can
be prepared to provide more detailed
information then and we're happy to
answer any additional questions that you
might have
at that time or be prepared for thank
you
oh thank you um
and we intend to have
lindsey courtney from the office of
professional licensure also joining us
in as well so that you can ask her
questions at the same time so you can
have both of us together
okay i see i really appreciate that and
and and there's a saying that goes
something like there are no solutions
there are only trade-offs and i just if
if there are disadvantages to moving it
i i'd like to know what those
disadvantages are even if on the net
it's still worth moving
does that make sense
thank you yes
thank you representative your hand is up
ma'am oh sorry
i just keep forgetting to put it down
um okay so at this point we've gone
through
hb2
uh
i think completely
um the department came with some
additional requests and representative
pearson sent some ideas
but before i
come off of this i just want to
double check with you mr ripple and
listen to representative irf
have we done all of the hb2 items that
are assigned to dhhs
to hhs yes there are five veterans home
related items that are assigned to
division three
okay so we're not talking about those
but we've not heard the veterans home
and hearing yet either so that's right
um
if you could ask them to do a twofer is
that is that possible to where we when
we're talking about their budget they
talk about their hp2 items
i have already asked them to talk about
that yes
thank you
uh representative if you had your hand
up sir
i took it down i can't answer my
questions thank you
okay
so
uh the next thing you're going to see
if you look at what i emailed you or if
you're looking at the shared screen
is
you're looking at
a cut and paste
from mr williams a note to us when he
came in and briefed us one day
and so i just wanted like i said we we
haven't had a conversation with one
another as a committee so i wanted to uh
to be able to do that today to see how
we are
um the first one is a footnote in
house bill one
and uh representative wallner the other
day was giving me a little education
about when a footnote is appropriate and
when an hb2 section
is more appropriate and
um so thank you for for that
representative wallner and and i would
like to ask you mr ripple
to just give us a a reminder or a
tutorial on
what are the uses and limits of a
footnote in hb1 and and then therefore
what should be going in an hb2
well generally speaking the hb1
footnotes apply only to the use of money
they don't make policy and they also
apply only to the biennium in question
they don't extend beyond that
taking a look at the proposed language
here my instinct is that it should
probably be in house bill 2 instead
because it states that the funds shall
be continually appropriated and
non-lapsing so they would be non-lapsing
beyond the current biennium
um
and so there are there are two footnotes
there one for the system of care and one
for the bdas or is your uh observation
the same for both i know my observation
really only pertained to the bdf bdas
example the
class 102 shall not lapse until june
30th 2023 looks
totally fine for house bill 1.
okay
so
um are there
any comments from the committee because
what i what i think i'm about to suggest
is that the department uh convert
um that first footnote
into proposed hb2 language
and that we now carry it as a footnote
in hb1
and
sorry karen does have her hand raised in
the audience so perhaps she has a
different perspective
i was just going to suggest that you
could add june 30th 2023 to that so that
it's actually appropriately a footnote
so you'd rather amend the footnote
instead of doing an hb2 yes
okay just so we don't screw it up would
you send us the replacement language
exactly how you would have it absolutely
thank you
and we're back to the idea of two
footnotes
uh are there any comments from the
committee
representative
i think you're trying to get your hand
up so you if you no
no i'm fine
i thought i had started to notice what
it looks like when you're trying to find
your button
all right um
so these will be
replacement
language
from department
and then we're gonna go
uh otherwise
okay as
hb1 footnotes
all right so now we're into uh hb2
language again
um
okay
i have not spent much time looking at
these things
to be frank
is
is is there anyone on the committee
that has put some heavy thought into any
of these proposals
i'm i'm not seeing any hand shooting up
that we've done any heavy thought about
these proposals
so so go ahead representative
where did we get where did these
proposals come from
mr williams and the department came in
oh gosh it's probably been two weeks ago
maybe two and a half weeks ago and uh
said that these were some hb2 items that
didn't get into the hb2 process but that
that the department wanted us to look at
it in this period
of time and decide to determine if we
could put it into our version of hb2 or
not so these are i believe are
late-breaking
hot topics
and i will just comment oh sorry go
ahead
no i'm just going to say so when when
the department comes back to talk about
all these other sections of hb2
couldn't they
spend some time talking about these also
and we could make a decision as to
whether we wanted to put them in or not
did you did you get a chance to say what
you wanted to mr ripple
i was just going to comment that the
first one is boilerplate that's been in
place for many years and it was
inadvertently left out i believe of
house bill 2.
so that's why they're proposing it
and also they would propose rather than
repealing only the indirect graduate
medical education doing the direct and
indirect
and actually as i read this now
this is another instance where typically
it's been a suspension
but the proposal here is for repeal
so it's not quite boilerplate
okay
so if the department thinks this is easy
to deal with by just sending us an email
about
this this particular language
maybe that'll help just close this
you you took a deep breath does that is
that going to work just ask the
department to
to
follow up with an email on what they
think we ought to do with this yep i
think that should be fine
representative irf
i just have a process question where do
i find the footnotes i know i can see
them in your document but
are they
where are they
i think that's for you mr ripple
where does one find the footnotes so the
house bill one footnotes um well i think
the proposed footnote isn't currently in
there so you wouldn't see that however
some accounting units do have
class notes or footnotes
in the operating budget if you're
looking at the pdf version
yeah
that they'll do
on any particular page or at the end or
uh just associated with a particular
accounting unit at the bottom of that
accounting unit you'll see a footnote so
they could be anywhere yes tough to pick
out
they can be yep okay
all right thank you
okay
so
uh oh representative weiler please
the uh big changes to the 529 program
they put in a minute
but anyway it took uh
money out of the fidelity
payment for the 529 program which is up
to almost 18 million we've been usually
passing on about 10 or 12. so a lot of
that money was grabbed
for the governor's scholarship plans and
this
particular area might be part of that
if you want to look at page 68 and see
the changes to the 529 program it it
kind of allows some scholarships for
medical training
and as well as the the
restorative medical thing
at the milliard
so take it took the extra money out of
the fidelity and put it in this
different commission and this this
governor scholarship program so
if that's the case a lot of the money
that came out of general funds for
scholarships which i think this was
can come out of that fidelity money
which is not appropriated
except from the 529 program
thank you uh do you have a a follow-up
to that sir your hand is still up i
don't want to leave without you
finishing
got it
represented nordgren
oh thank you i think the genesis of this
um was the concern for the lack of
health care in the north country
and i think um the recipients of this
were
students and
uh
care providers who
went to the north country in particular
and then received
this aid thanks
thank you representative
so kevin is it possible to get a list of
all the footnotes because when you look
at the spreadsheet obviously you don't
see footnotes and i just searched for
footnote in the
http one and all it went to was the last
section of proposed budget sections
and clearly in these footnotes you could
hide all kinds of things i mean height
is probably the wrong word you could
include all kinds of things
yeah they might be called class notes
instead um
but i can i can get you a list sure
thank you
so
so as i look at this i just generally
wonder why we're reducing our
support for graduate medical education
when we have a workforce shortages but
there must be a brilliant reason for
that
uh we'll we'll schedule another
conversation around this
um
okay
i think i think i'm ready to move on to
um the comments we got from chairman
pearson of hhs
okay
all right so
uh
this is basically an abstract of an
email he sent us
uh he he he wants to make sure that we
don't cut any benefits going to the area
agencies for care of a developmentally
delayed population
we finally eliminated the wait list
before the pandemic but the wait list
seems possible again
seeing the impact
a severely dd person has on families i
note that while putting dd people on the
wait list may save staffing money we
also lose in the other direction loved
ones who want to work often can't
so so this isn't really an hb2 item but
because it was coming in over from the
policy committee i just wanted everyone
to to see that i i think that is meant
to reflect
kind of a summary position or consensus
position of the policy committee and not
just uh chairman uh pearson's uh
personal beliefs
so uh representative norgren do you have
a comment
well um i don't remember getting this
email so could you maybe send it out
again to all of us
okay i okay sure
um
you probably don't remember getting it
because you probably didn't get it
oh okay
thanks
okay so then the other thing that um
he talked about and this is this is uh
around the the the debt the dental care
for medicaid program
and the summary position was that dental
dental care is actually a cost-effective
thing and his argument is essentially
that if somebody
has severe
oral health problems and diseases that
that infects their entire
immune system and just causes them to
get
even sicker
causing more emergency room use and and
um you know at that point you have to do
a tooth extraction because it's a
medical issue it's covered by medicaid
so
so they're
they're
suggesting
that they have a bill coming
and let me see if they answered the
question
because i've been asking them what they
did with it in committee
um
oh so they had
hb 103 that was their dental medicaid
program and they
amended it and then they retained it and
then there's supposed to be another
senate bill on a similar topic working
its way over to the house
and so this this dental medicaid program
is not
actually in law
um so so i guess as much as i've been
trying to mentally reserve money for it
in fy 23 we don't have anything to
to
there is not a program for us to fund at
this point
mr ripley
is that right
not actually an existing program there
is not a program currently in effect
there was language in the prior trailer
bill
stating that a dental benefit shall be
in effect by april 1st of 2021 so that
requirement does
exist in current law
but the program is not up and running
so we could reach back to that and fund
it if we wanted to with an hb2 with an
appropriation
is that is that a possibility
yes yeah
okay
so
not knowing how our hb1 conversations
are going to go
let's let's see if we can talk about
that around the 22nd of march
okay
are there
any comments about um
medicaid dental
i'm not i'm not seeing any
um and so uh i want to see if we can
take
at least one vote to get something off
of our plate just to see how this goes
um and
uh
i so i want us i want this to be our
first vote it's going to have to be a
roll call vote
uh i think uh according to you know
basic rules i would need
a motion in a second
uh i i think that's the procedures we
use in this committee
um
i would like to see a motion on section
20.
uh
believing that the consensus of the
committee is that that we ought to
include this
in our hb2 language
is is there a motion
i didn't rehearse this part with anyone
i'll move
foreign
accept
section 20.
second
seconded by representative
representative erf
do you want to speak to your motion
no i think it like you say it's
boilerplate it's it's been in there a
while
and i think we need to remind them again
oh okay very good i'm sorry you can have
her second and that's fine
you got it i think i think according the
rules you only need to record who makes
the motion you don't actually need to
record the second but
but any case
um okay is there any further discussion
okay if there is no further discussion
i would like to
uh have us a vote on whether or not
division three
is going to accept section 20 of the
governor's proposed house bill 2.
would you
take a roll call please mr clerk
representative irf
yes
representative wylo votes yes
representative bean
yes
representative walner yes
representative nordgren
yes
representative rogers yes
representative edwards
chairman votes yes
vote is seven to zero
okay
standing
um
all right
so
um so that was good that was good
practice i wanted to understand how we
did that
and and given that we have
um
under an hour left and that we have mr
lippman
on the line waiting
why don't we why don't we respect his
time
and ask him to
jump in
to talk to us about i think i think
section 27
relative to the new hampshire granite
advantage healthcare trust fund
good evening
good afternoon ashley good afternoon mr
chairman um are you able to hear me okay
yes
so um
in 2018 um
the legislature passed
house bill 1817
which uh dealt with um
the use of uh the met proceeds
to fund uh disproportionate share for
hospitals at that time
it was anticipated based on changes in
federal law that
um
it that the dish proportion share funds
may not be the only
vehicle in which
the funding to hospitals might occur
in fact the legislation spoke to
the use of directed payments and
supplemental payments or rate increases
and so what
this language is intended to do is to
permit
those funds that would have
paid
to hospitals directly as a dish payment
out of met proceeds since they um
going forward starting in 21 to 22 and
forward probably won't all be able to be
made by dish payments in order to
satisfy hb 1817
which is
codified with the rsa citation that you
have and you're right up here
to the extent that funds from met which
were intended to pay dish
are needed instead to pay either a
directed payment or
a supplemental payment or whatever under
um the granted advantage program that
that that portion of the met proceeds
could be used to do so so basically it's
a zero-sum game in the sense that um
a certain percentage of the
collected tax is intended to to fund
hospital um
payments uh and the balance of it is
used to fund other parts of
dhhs and so this isn't really
creating a new uh thing it's just the
fact that the
there's a different type of payment that
has to be made and
and and uh met would be otherwise have
been the source of that payment
negatively in effect revenues to nursing
care
programs
this this particular tax is uh solely
for
the hospitals sector and then provider
payments none of which are related to
nursing facilities
representative you have a question
thank you uh
so mr lippman this gives us the
flexibility that we didn't have with the
original met
which is why we got sued i don't know 10
15 years ago because we uh charge it to
the hospital in accordance with what
they build and all their and all their
bills and then we tried to give it back
to them but some of them hadn't had
enough medicaid
payments that uh we couldn't justify it
the feds wouldn't allow us to give the
whole mob back so
we had to work out something and so
hopefully this is what that workout is
all these many years later and it uh
gave us some lawsuits perhaps so i i
think this is a good idea and i favor it
as the sponsor of the original met many
years ago thank you
thank you representative
are there any other
questions i i'd i'd be willing to
entertain a motion that the committee
accept section 27 of house bill 2.
again we didn't rehearse this
before you continue could i just make
one comment which is that you don't
actually have to take affirmative votes
on every item that you want to leave in
if you wanted to you could just take a
vote on the items that you want to amend
um
and that's the way division three has
done it in previous years that said
there's there's certainly nothing wrong
with voting on each item if that's the
way you want to go about
it we get to the same place which way
gets there fastest without um
missing anything
just tell kevin you want to put it in
leave it in
that i'm just i'm just looking i'm just
trying to make sure though that i don't
say leave it in when there's uh
opposition and the opposition's not been
able to be heard publicly
that's fine and this is a perfectly
valid way to go about it i just want to
let you know that you don't have to be
if you'd rather not
i just don't want to
have a process that
runs over
opposing points of view
okay
so
um
okay can can i get a
a motion on section 27 anyone willing to
move that we accepted
i i will
re-state restate my motion
receptive
okay who made the motion now
the motion is that the division three
accept section 27
related to the new hampshire granted
advantage health care trust fund
and
who made the motion in a second
okay so i'm putting down earth and
weiler is second
follow a roll
okay
um
representative earth
yes
representative uh
weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes
representative walner
representative nordgren
yes
representative rogers
representative edwards
uh yes
four to seven to zero
okay uh thank you and and i realized
once the voting started that i didn't
offer an opportunity to discuss it so
um but i since we all voted yes i
apparently there wasn't any discussion
uh
okay
that will probably be our last vote of
the day because i want to talk to folks
about the smartest way to proceed on on
getting these approved my goal
is to be efficient and effective but i
don't want to
have anyone's voice um not heard
so if somebody wants to talk to me about
that later we'll come up with another uh
idea
so so mr
is if mr lipman is still there i am sir
um
i my notes were not all that great where
i can search on your name and find the
places that you were able to talk to
do you do you recall any of these that
you thought that you would like to speak
to
yes i think there were two and
i'm trying to remember which numbers
they are see i've got my cliff notes
here um
[Music]
i think the suspension of catastrophic
aid was one of them
um
and the second one was
let's do that and then maybe mr williams
can figure out the second one while
you're talking
so i think uh as representative walner
had uh
uh
spoken to earlier i think it's actually
dme and ime is the other one and they
both fit into the same category i think
um
it's been the case that as
as you know as a committee you have a
challenge um
meeting the the budget targets you need
to make and i think in these couple of
areas um
it's been uh historically carried hb 2
for a number of different bienniums
that rather than
ending these things
if there's an opportunity to fund them
that in the future that
that they've left them in the posture
similar to the one that was
included i think it was an oversight and
hp
hb2 drafting
to not include um
the
the one that was not included in there
mr williams can
jump in here for a minute i think it was
the
suspension of catastrophic aid is in
here and is i think needed to just as a
placeholder the ime and dme
excuse me i indirect medical education
and direct medical education are
also that category that they're just not
able to be funded at this point and i
think in terms of the provider community
understands that
and in relationship to
you know your earlier vote on number 27
i think that's that's part of the whole
big picture
okay you know representative you you
wanted to
retain this and discuss it further do
you um well
no i just wanted to hear what mr lipman
had to say
and i think he has just talked on this
one
um
and
i mean i feel i feel like it makes sense
to leave it in here
representative nordgren do you have
questions
pardon me
i guess the question is
do we want the word suspend
um
rather than just not funding it for this
year
representative i think the reason
suspension is used so that we can
don't have to take it out of the state
plan and then some future time
go through the process of putting it in
it's i think a simpler way to give the
state the flexibility um
if if and when it's able to do so
okay representative your hand is still
up to you no
no i think it makes sense i mean
i would hate to have to see you change
the state plan and then have to change
it back again
if something happened so to me it makes
sense
you want to make a motion on section 36
relative to catastrophic aid payments to
hospitals
sure i will make a motion that we
uh leave this section in
house bill 2.
here in a second i don't know if we need
a second
second
okay
thank you
so uh mr clerk would you call a roll
the motion being
uh the uh division three uh is voting to
accept section 36
relative to suspension of catastrophic
aid
we payments a motion in a second is that
correct yes sir i think we're i think
we're ready for a roll call
all right representative earth
yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes representative walner
yes
representative
representative rogers yes
representative edwards
yes
mr chairman of the voter 7-0
okay
all right
so
um mr lippman uh while we've been
talking uh did mr williams tell you the
other one that we want to talk about
graduate medical education and direct it
was uh yes i remember i remembered it
here um because i think that that was
um
if you will have been carried in other
hb2s and we would like to be continued
to be carried in this one i think it was
an oversight that it got um
not included in the agency
okay so this one's a little bit
different because these are these are
brand new notes they're not in hb2
currently
right right there it was left left out
so mr ripple what would be the process
if the commit or well first
as you're reading these do you think
these are sufficient for us to put into
hb2 this this first one looks more
cooked than the second
portion of it i don't see any language
i think sorry i think the graduate
medical education payments piece is okay
except you would want to say direct as
well as indirect and we could have we
would have this drafted uh as a house
bill 2 amendment from ols anyway so you
would get a formal amendment to vote on
i guess the only other thing again that
i would point out is that as written
this is a repeal rather than a
suspension as has been in previous
trailer bills
so it's actually possible that the
department may want to take just a quick
second look at this to get it the way
they want it is that possible
i'll work with john on that
okay
so we have
40 minutes still
um
maybe we could try an alternative way of
taking things off of our plate
representative walner
there was uh an issue here on the foster
grandparent program
and we were going to
leave this open
are there questions that you have for
the department that would help you
figure out if you want this to be
included or not
um i would i mean i would suspend
the program and not repeal it
um i think it's
a program that we've gone back and forth
over the years
um
we haven't even finished house bill one
yet and
lo and behold
we find a pot of gold it might be
something we would want to
to include um this is a really fun
especially the foster grandparent
program is
really
a
fantastic program for
elderly people who
still have the energy and want to work
with kids
they work in schools they work in child
care centers um
and they get paid a very small stipend
and the income eligibility to be a
foster grandparent is so low but it does
help them and it's it's absolutely
fantastic for the kids
because they get to spend time with an
older adult
and um so i would just like to see us at
least leave it on suspension and not
repeal
okay
are there any committee members that
politely disagree with representative
waller that they want to keep this a
repeal
or
or do we agree that a suspension is a
better way to go or or do we just
want to strike this from hb2
it's kind of the floor is open
representative irv could somebody give
me the correct number so i can actually
get to and read it
well i thought it was section 22 but
there's two okay
thank you
if it's not
let us know the correct number it's it's
21 22 or 23 it's in that neighborhood 22
seems to be senior volunteer grant
program is that the grandparents thing
it's 22 and i think it covers everything
it covers congregate services and the
senior volunteer grant program
and that but that's referencing the
grandparents
yes
okay and the senior volunteer is that a
similar kind of thing
yeah the other one you mentioned
i believe one was included in the
broader program so i'd have to take a
look at the way
i have to take a look at how it's
written but i think the foster
grandparent program is part of the
senior volunteer grant program
okay and i guess i'm ready to go just i
just i wasn't really prepared for this
and i'm the first one to vote
yeah no it doesn't sound like uh it
sounds like mr ripple wants to just look
into it a little bit more before we take
it off the plate
not that i'm not supportive i'd just
like to know the general sense of the
committee
so so let's do a general sense of the
committee are we
do we do we think representative wallner
is right when she says this should be a
suspension and not a repeal
representative nordgren
yes that was the motion i was going to
make
so so because this is not ready to vote
um
and mr ripple is is just going to double
check uh check it a little bit
um
let's let's just leave the suspend item
open and and talk about it next week
representative walter your hand is still
up did you have further comment
nope nope
it's fine thank you
and so that
so 2023
got rolled into 22 so so that would
that's all one section all right
um
okay mr williams if you're still there
you were going to tell us some more
about
the section 23 department of hhs social
services block grant
adjustment
and and mr chair thank you very much
and so before addressing i just wanted
to to let you know mr chair that we did
line up uh for today to support the
division three as well as mr ripple uh
with subject matter experts on various
sections on this bill including as
you've heard from mr lipman so if you
have some additional time and want to
utilize those folks who have uh uh spent
the time to monitor this to be
questions but otherwise certainly will
defer to you if you would like us to do
this at a later time as well but we do
have folks out here who could help with
perhaps additional
sections
so so did you not hear me ask you to
talk about section 23.
yes you did thank you very much so
section 23 uh deals with the social
services block grant and if i could have
included in the conversation uh wendy
director wendy altman because she can
certainly provide some additional
background uh regarding this but as
we're bringing her in i can give you a
very high level of what we're looking to
do
as you probably are aware that this has
been an item that's been in the budget
for well over a decade as long as i've
been doing my work legislatively and
it's a requirement that we make certain
adjustments based upon a cost of living
based upon the social security uh
benefits that are out there
as you'll know this is a very modest
increase that is required under federal
law and we're required to having this
provision within the context of hb2 and
it's been in the budget for like i
mentioned over a decade and at least by
information from social security uh for
the 70 million americans who do
currently receive this cost living
increase
in 2021 that increase is a
1.3 so we're talking about a very very
small sum of money however it's
important uh obviously to have included
as part of the budget
so other than the language that is
boiler language that's already contained
in house bill 2 as introduced in section
23 found on page 10 line 10
we were also looking to have some
additional language uh included within
it to create greater efficiencies not
only for the executive branch the
department but also for the legislature
by way of background last
biennium in hb4 which was the trailer
built to the budget in 2019
we actually
thought up an idea that was a very good
one working along with the legislature
working along with the governor's office
that um there was a provision that it
related to long-term care that we were
required to going before the joint uh
committee on administrative rules uh
every uh every budget session even
though the changes that were being made
were static in nature so was it it was
deemed to be an unnecessary process for
us to have to go
in addition to the language within um
the the budget we also had to go to the
joint administrative uh committee on
administrative rules could i interrupt
you a second are you still talking about
section 23 it feels like
yes yes all right keep going
so what we're suggesting and it was part
of the uh language that was provided by
mr ripple and it was part of our
discussions on the additional add-on and
i'm just going i can certainly stop if
you want us to stay in the context of
section 23 we can but there was an
additional request by the department to
consider
language so that the department once we
make these particular adjustments uh to
the social services block grant based
upon the cost of living adjustments
that the current law that requires us to
also go to the joint committee on
administrative rules that we could get a
carve out for not having to do that as
long as we provide the public with
appropriate notification and that's what
we're seeking to do with the additional
language
okay so so i'm i'm a simple guy what i
think i just heard you say
is that you like what's in section 23
but doesn't include as much as you'd
like so you've sent in a
an alternative section 23 that you'd
like us to review
and that addition
is would change your reporting
requirements over to
a different part of the house
um essentially that's very close i have
to make one distinction because the
amendment because section 23 is based
upon chapter law and not embedded in a
rsa
we're looking actually to in addition to
section 23 to adding an additional
section to hb2 that is directly directly
related to the same section around the
social services block grant
to include an amendment under rsa 541
dash a colon 21 roman uh 3a
to uh to essentially amend
the current requirement under the
administrative uh procedures act in new
hampshire to
allow a carve out to the department does
not have to also go to the joint
committee on administrative roles
every time to making these these
adjustments which are uh
i kind of heard that i'm just i'm just
looking for steps and so
the step that i i'm curious about is
is that language drafted and it is is it
in the possession of the lba it is
granted and is in the possession of mr
ripple
so it's it's not on the list of things
that we were prepared to talk about
today
but uh mr chair it was provided on the
initial discussions that we had had uh
relative it's in that same document that
has the hb1 footnote language as well as
language that mr lipman talked about for
inclusion as it related to the direct
and indirect uh graduate medical
expenses so i thought it just made sense
where this language was also included in
that same document that for some
efficiency that we presented
at this stage
okay well so maybe i'm the one that uh
overlooked it um
but uh but we're not prepared to to look
at your language today so we're gonna
have to schedule it uh in the future
it's kind of the bottom line
everything you're saying is sounding
reasonable it's just we're not
you know from a stepwise perspective
we're just not ready to
to look at it as a committee and talk
about it
uh if if you wouldn't mind just sending
exactly what you're talking about again
with a clear title uh i'm i'm not likely
to lose it twice
representative do you have a question
thank you mr chair i'm wondering how
much money is in this is it general
funds or
federal funds and what's the
amount of the increase
thank you and mr chair uh to to respond
to representative wyler's question i
would defer either to miss rounds or to
miss altman they'll be able to explain
uh what the mix is in terms of the
federal and the state match and where
it's located within the budget
okay
i don't have that information off hand
wendy i'm not sure if you do
hi
uh this is wendy altman i'm the bureau
chief of the bureau of elderly adult
services so one of the questions was
what the polar or what the income limit
is um as of this year and that's um 1
314 dollars and 30 cents for an
individual that's the eligibility
income and it is a
combination of federal
social service block grant title 20
funding and general funds but i i don't
have in front of me the
the percent mix
okay
so so it's it sounds like we do have
multiple reasons for deferring the
conversation away from
now
and uh
so we'll
uh
we'll we'll come up with uh
when we plan to talk about these again
and you'll have time to get your your
notes together are there are there any
other questions uh representing weiler
that was a great question are there any
other questions we want to bring back
into this representative irf
could i ask but
if we're going to look at this again we
get all this information ahead of time
that relates to these so we have time to
actually review it i understand uh mr
williams said we did get a document
before and i don't doubt that
um but i didn't relate it to this today
unfortunately
and and mr chairman responding to
represent earth's uh um uh ask of the
department so in preparation for for
today and perhaps it was my
misunderstanding of the the overall
purpose is that not knowing all the
questions that could arise here is the
reason why uh that i coordinated working
with miss rounds to having around 10 to
15 subject matter experts including
directors with our department available
to you to respond to your questions so
as the questions arise that we're not
able to actually answer your questions
we certainly will work diligently to get
you further detailed information point
in case the example from uh director
altman around the federal state uh
matching proportions and getting back to
you on that but absent knowing
specifically what your questions are
makes it a little bit difficult
for for us to kind of figure those out
in a vacuum but we are prepared to at
least explain you know what the language
does to give you a very transparent
picture
of why they are included within the
budget and we were prepared today to do
that on many of these items but again i
would defer to the chair because i
believe it was my misunderstanding of
the depth of which uh the division three
was going to
go into these particular sections today
okay
you wouldn't possibly know mr williams
because we didn't talk about it
but today is sort of a day of
celebration for me because this is
actually the first time that the
committee has been able to interactively
talk to each other to level set what
we're thinking about hb2
and because we are prevented under
rsa 98 or 91a
to to have sidebar meetings to work all
this stuff out in advance we have to
have these conversations in public so
that we are transparent
and and that's and that's really what
the purpose of today was is to have the
first two and a half hour discussion to
see the extent to which we are
aligned or we are going to have issues
and and as a result of talking about it
it's natural that questions that nobody
anticipated
comes up because this is really the
first time we've had an opportunity to
speak to one another and effectively end
up brainstorming where one person's
comment may trigger another thought in
another person it's i think that
brainstorming is just a natural part of
of teamwork and i'm sorry
if uh if it's caused a lot of members of
dhhs to spend their friday afternoon
with us listening to us talking to one
another but but that's the stage that we
were in today
um
representative erf
perhaps we could take advantage of
all the folks being here to
go through the items and ask questions
without the specific intent to then
process them today
that is exactly what i was trying to do
but for the third time i heard how
everyone was brought here today to talk
about
things so
so we'll get to that
are there any other areas that we've
brought up that the department would
like to speak up on that we've asked
questions i've been taking notes and
trying to run the meeting and
am not
ready to go directly
to where we've talked before and we've
left it open for the department
representative edwards this is wendy
altman from the bureau of elderly and
adult services
i'd like to
just have a moment to be able to answer
one of the previous questions about
the foster grandparent program in the
congregate meals program
i know that representative walner
had mentioned that it's been suspended
for
before um but we do know that it's been
uh over 10 years um that these programs
have been suspended um and they just
every time the biennium comes up they
they get resuspended again um and
specifically with the congregate housing
program this was something where we
attributed general funds to the program
but it did not pay
solely a hundred percent for the program
there were federal dollars that um
primarily contributed to the congregate
housing um becoming operational and that
federal funding is not no longer
available um so attributing general
funds to the program may
um
would not necessarily implement or
operationalize a program um so
in the past when we've re-established
these um and brought it forward one of
the issues um was that hud funds weren't
being contributed it to any longer um so
that's why we put it forward to be
repealed
thank you for that is so your bottom
line is you think a a repeal is the
right way to go and not a suspension
correct
and mr church
if i president
representative do you have a question
you're on mute i i think your mouths are
saying no
okay sorry about that um
i just was trying to check
house bill one i thought that we had
i thought we had had some funding for
foster grandparent program
in the last biennium
but i i certainly could be wrong
sorry no uh if i could interject yes
they were both congregate housing and
foster grandparents were both funded in
the 2021 budget
congregate housing at 750 000 per year
of general funds and foster grandparent
at 100 000 per year general funds
great thank you i thought that they were
both funded in the last um in the last
budget thank you
great memory uh so so ms aldman did did
i mishear you it sounded like there
hadn't been funding and that's why you
think
a repeal is appropriate do you still
think that
yes i think that in in the past um
advocates
especially in biennium
2021 advocates um had advocated for that
funding to be put in
and unsuspend
the statute
however
the congregate housing program
general funds would only contribute a
very small portion to a congregate
housing program that no longer has
federal funding
um so we would not be able to
operationalize a congregate housing
program with those funds therefore we
put forward for it to be repealed this
time
and
john williams can chime in in terms of
the funding that was put into the budget
but i don't believe that it was part of
the agency request that the department
put forward um
getting that funding
this is karen and i can actually add to
that so that i think um just to add to
what wendy's saying there
the funding wasn't sufficient in fiscal
year 20 and 21 in addition to the fact
that we um did not have the capacity to
stand something like that up because of
the other demands on the department um
so
i think that's that's a clarification
that needs to be made is that the
general funds were not enough so it if
you took this section out of hb2
completely um
it would be a mandate without funding
we
there would have to be general funds
added to the budget in addition to
positions to run the programs um
to be able to take this out of hv2
completely
to ask a clarifying question it sounds
to me like the uh foster grandparent
program is distinct really from the
congregate housing issue and the
congregate housing issue
requires a lot more investment than
my perception of a grandfather or a
grandparent foster program
but yet these are being put together and
and all of it's being repealed is is
everything you're saying about
congregate housing being kind of too too
expensive to really get off the ground
with a little bit of federal money
that's been provided is that also true
for
the
foster grandparent program
uh could we do this could i um
i believe that we're tying them together
because federally the program was was
tied together when it was federally
funded so if we could um come back to
you on the foster grandparent side and
just give you a sense of what it would
cost
to fully implement that program um i
think that would be helpful if jonah
could add that to the list of questions
for the department
it would be good for me and mr chair
john williams if i could add a
historical perspective just for a second
i'd rather hear representative walner's
question uh we we don't have much more
time and we're really looking at the
next budget
yeah well
i i i thought that the
100 000 for the foster grandparent
program was basically
a state donation to a to a larger
program a program that gets federal
funding directly it doesn't flow through
the department
the department doesn't run the program
it's almost like a contract in that they
make a contribution to a larger program
am i misunderstanding that
i i don't know the answer to that but
let me
let me get back to you on all of that
information because it may be that i
misunderstood that
do you have an answer for that question
i i'd like to get back to you with that
information
representative your hand is up
but i would like to see an analysis
of how many programs where the staffing
exceeds the money distributed
i think that sounds like that that's
what would have happened with those
foster grandparents and the congregate
housing
that the staffing would have taken all
the money and there'd be nothing left to
give it to the program i wonder how many
other
programs hhs has where the staffing
is greater than the amount that's
distributed
for that program thank you
we do that in a two-step
answer first step is just to
verify
representative weiler's observation that
maybe the our own internal personnel
costs
tended to exceed the money that we were
getting from the feds and and then with
that in place
get to the second part which is are
there similar programs
follow-up meeting
yes i i think the the second question it
i think
that's a difficult
question to answer and i need to spend
some time thinking about the question
and see it in writing um
before i can commit to how long it might
take to put something like that together
that's that's reasonable how about the
first part of it where he he he's he's
drawn the observation from listening to
you all
that
the
cost of our personnel to run the program
exceeded the money that we were getting
from the federal government
i don't know that that would be
necessarily true so i'll
i think we can put that into the answer
about the foster grandparent program
specifically
that address your issue representative
weiler
i would think with the computer i.t we
have if you looked at
any program class 50 plus class 10
and then the total cost of the program
it would be revealing
so that's the sort of information i'm
interested in is class 10 and class 50
are more than half of the program
thank you
representative norton
i'm sorry did you have a response yeah i
was just going to say i do understand
that um concept i i think the
the issue is that the system is kept by
accounting units and there can be
several accounting units for each
program and several programs within each
accounting unit so it's not quite as
simple
as that unfortunately
representative
you took your hand down do you still
have a question though ma'am
all right
um
representative edwards um if i may just
be able to answer um representative
wallner's question
in relation to foster grandparent
program
um i believe that
in the past more than 10 years ago when
the program
was
being funded or contracted out it did
it did help to
support
a larger
foster grandparent program that existed
and
we did contract that out but the program
had been suspended for
more than
um 10 years so
um
we'd have to be able to get back to you
in terms of how it would what it would
look like if it were funded but my
understanding is that it's not funded
and it's been suspended for 10 years we
wouldn't be able to
answer that second question in terms of
the staffing um it was a contracted out
program and we didn't have state staff
operating
uh thank you ms altman
so we we have another 10 minutes or so
um
mr williams with with the the collective
uh genius that's with you is there any
part of what we've talked about as a
committee that you would like to address
or answer for us given that you've heard
our conversation and
and uh mr chair thank you so much and uh
for that opportunity
uh as to the historical context it's
very brief but i think it would be
helpful
that on those sections that we're
seeking to repeal currently that were
suspended for a number of years and i
know uh for for representative wyler and
other members like rev walner
that because they've been suspended for
so long we were actually asked by the
legislature during the budget process
and particularly in the house
if you've been suspending these for so
many years why don't we in the same way
that you identified for example
the prospective repeal let's say let's
just deal with it now and get it out of
the budget so you don't have to deal
with moving forward and there have been
other examples that mr ripple certainly
could point to as well as i
where you've done some gardening in the
past taking out items that no longer are
required to be part of hp2 we really
appreciate that because it means it's
one less item that has to be identified
everybody by ending when you're
constructing a budget so whether you
suspend our repeal i just wanted to give
you the context that it actually was a
conversation that happened
a couple of budget sessions ago
regarding trying to clean up those
sections but whether it's suspended or
repealed as ms rounds had pointed out we
just need to have some language in there
to cover for us whether you decide
eventually to suspend some of those
sections or to repeal but i just thought
that would be helpful for you to have
that that background
thank you mr williams representative do
you have a question
yes i just want to make one further
point and that is that if it was in
the last budget
which it is
the foster grandparent program is at
least i know
if it's in there
then it wasn't repealed i mean it
obviously wasn't repealed
and my question now is
if it was in the last budget
did they not get their hundred thousand
dollars
or alternatively where did that hundred
thousand dollars go
i don't want to put words in your mouth
but you're basically looking for how
that hundred thousand dollars actually
got used if it did or not
yes thank you
this is this is karen um they did not
get contracted out and those funds will
lapse at
the end of this biennium
[Music]
do you have a follow-up representative
no just very disappointed to hear that
that sounds like a great program
um
all right so
uh i'll come back to you uh mr williams
um
is there anything that we've talked
about or asked questions about which
hasn't already been discussed in the
last 40 minutes
that the department would like to weigh
in on before we close today's hearing
so so mr chair i think what would be
helpful is i can we can certainly work
myself and miss rounds to get to have at
the next uh convening the same group of
people we have here today just be
available to answer questions as you go
through the sections to give you some
some context at least from the
department's perspective on what these
actually do and why they're needed as
part of the language in hb2 but for
today it's been a long day and i would
not want to take up
any more of your time unless at your
direction you would like us to proceed
any further today
all right well thank you for that i'm
going to actually try one more step
forward and uh to the committee
uh there's this section 31 that i i
nicknamed the weiler rule
on um
on being notified if uh if there are any
budgetary impacts due to program
eligibility
uh
my note says i assume everyone's okay
with that
so
um
so i'd like to get this off of our plate
if we can because we have another nine
minutes or so um
is
if i could get a motion on accepting
uh section 31
that's actually section 32 i'm sorry no
i really appreciate you fixing that
before we did that thank you
so section 32
um
yes representative earth
were you going to make a motion
to to
have the committee accept
section 32
no i was just trying to find it but uh
kevin help me find it
is there a motion to accept section 32
i'll move
wider
second
i just want could i ask kevin a question
yes ma'am is it about this motion
about section third okay yeah it is and
kevin this has been in this is the exact
wording that's been in here for quite a
few years
well off the top of my head i don't want
to commit to it being exact but i i
i think so
right it looks really familiar
it looks exact
let me just um i think it's been 15
years
yeah no i think it does look
i just didn't compare it to last year
mary kalista's telling me it is exactly
the same
okay great thank you you're welcome
is there any other discussion
seeing no discussion would the clerk
call a role
representative earth yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes
representative walder yes
representative nordgren
yes
representative rogers yes
representative edwards
yes
mr chairman of the voters 7-0
okay
thank you so much um
i think uh given the time of day and the
fact that i wanted to shut down before 2
30 i don't know that we have any other
um hb2 business that we can take up at
this time
[Music]
so i'll just open it up to the committee
members if there's uh
any comments or feedback that they want
to share i think actually representative
weiler i'm really going to put you on
the spot with this one
uh i think i think you made some casual
comments before the hearing started and
uh i i would i was distracted at the
time but i'm wondering if you want to
say that while we're still
in a public meeting so that we we've got
it on the record do you remember what
you were talking about
i'm trying to remember now
remember you're saying we'll talk about
that later but now
i've had so many things in my mind since
i don't remember exactly what i said
yes sir i'm sorry to put you on the spot
i just i just wanted
to make sure we were
all being transparent so representative
nordgren do you have a comment
um we just got a notice from janet that
our meeting on monday is at 10 o'clock i
just wanted to verify that
so if i could comment on that you did
get that it doesn't replace the meeting
that starts at 9 30 but this gets back
to what i was saying earlier about the
calendar didn't reference a work session
on monday and it didn't reference house
bill 1 and 2 specifically
so i got in touch with the clerk
and he suggested that a new
notice be put out for a work session
following
uh the monday morning meeting that's
already been noticed so janet sent out
that
that additional notice for a 10 o'clock
work session obviously that'll be
delayed in practice
when you're done with public health and
when you're done with the veterans home
you can move on to the work session but
as long as it's been properly noticed i
think you're good to talk about house
bill 2 on monday now
bottom line we're still meeting at 9 30.
yes
um
okay so um before we uh adjourn for the
day does anyone else on the committee
have any comments or questions for the
good of the committee
i can tell you what my intent is my
intent
is to take the notes that uh i i
scrambled together today
and go through them
and attempt to um
uh put some thought into when we can
come back to some of these subjects at a
future date
and to and to do that in a way
i i don't know that needs to go into an
official house calendar notice but i do
want to do it in a way in which we can
share it with our colleagues over in the
department so that
they don't they don't waste much time
waiting for us that's my intent
so um is there any comment question
i think what i said earlier was that
none of these items had a dollar sign
near them so when we vote for hb2
it's
likely adding to the budget but we don't
know how much
i think that's a fair observation in
many cases
so far it feels to me like the ones that
we've
approved
didn't have a a
didn't increase the spend i agree
all right
um are there any other comments or
questions because i think that's about
it
uh i want to thank everyone from the
department mr williams mr whitman ms
rounds ms altman
[Music]
thank you very much have a wonderful
weekend
and with that we stand adjourned
thank you